all right we got the story from
timcast.com Trump receives presidential
welcome from East Palestine officials
renders relief amid Biden's absence from
region Trump this is really America
right here we are standing in America
and boy is he correct former president
Donald Trump has traveled to East
Palestine to survey the damage and
Recovery efforts following the 38-car
derailment of a Norfolk Southern Train
carrying hazardous materials officials
from East Palestine welcomed the former
president with the chief of the East
Palestine fire department offering him a
briefing one might expect President Joe
Biden to receive were he not otherwise
occupied in foreign territories who
wrote this one Brett McDonald I love the
just like it's kind of a jab without
being a jab it's just a factual
statement check out how the daily wire
wrote it up I love this one from Daily
Mail I know this menu better than all of
you Trump orders Big Macs or East
Palestine First Responders and himself
after delivering 13 pallets of food and
Trump water to families betrayed by
Biden after toxic
I'm sorry man I where's the picture of
the this is great Trump standard
McDonald's order two Big Macs two filet
of fish and a chocolate shake that is
horrible wow uh the Flair fish is like
Delicious By the way but I that's a lot
of food for one person where's the
picture of the Trump water they got
Trump water on it look at this Trump
water I love it of course this this is
what I absolutely love about Trump
he will come down and he will help all
of these desperate people and He will
slap his name on the water bottle yeah
really well to be fair this is what
really annoyed me during the Trump
Administration among many other things
they would mock Trump over Trump water
Trump magazine and Trump stake and what
they wouldn't tell you is that this was
these were brand products for his Golf
Resorts yep so when you go to Walmart
and they've got the Walmart brand it's
good great value or whatever when you go
to a grocery store and they have their
name there that's all it is they were
acting like Trump was selling Trump
water in grocery stores so I went to
Trump Doral once
and they were all to all the Liberals
were like Trump water went out of
business and Trump magazine is gone I
walk in I walk in the hotel room and I
look down at the table on this Trump
magazine the bottle of trump water and
I'm like what are these people talking
about these are companies that Donald
Trump owns that provide these materials
to his Resorts so Trump has a bunch of
these water bottles probably from a
bunch of different Resort properties and
he said grab what we got ship it out
every everybody knows that you go into a
hotel and there's bottles of water
and it'll have the hotel's brand name on
it typically not not always depending on
the the the tier the star rating or
whatever but Trump has pallets of water
at these hotels and just had load up on
my truck we'll pay for shipping and then
we can give these to people who need
them win win win for everybody yep well
anything they can do to make them look
bad that's what they're going to do and
and they'll they'll stretch the truth or
just an outright lie about it but one
thing I did like about this was that
this is the first sign that I've seen of
2015-2016 trump oh yeah in a long time
because he's been really out of the loop
he was kicked off Twitter kicked off
Facebook that's not his fault but that
left him with it left him unconnected
from what made him president you know
and so this is the first signs of life
I've seen going back to that kind of old
school what made him president in 2015.
I don't see anything negative about what
he just did this is amazing negative has
there been lash like I'm not seeing any
any what can the corporate press say
about Trump right now to bring him down
yeah but here's the thing if they come
out and I'm sure they could come up with
something to attack Trump over but all
that would serve to do is highlight that
Trump is there and Biden is not and
where's Booty judge did he show up no no
yeah you know what I don't care if it's
a photo op literally don't care he
brought water with him by all means if a
photo op means people in need get the
help they need then that's better
leadership than what Biden is offered I
certainly wouldn't call it a photo it'd
be a photo if he was there looking
around and they took pictures but this
is he's giving people life life
sustenance right he's also giving them
air you know he's giving them air time
that they normally wouldn't get and and
that's been the problem right now we
were all talking about Chinese balloons
while this was happening and you know
I'm sure that's a serious thing but it
seemed to overshadow this giant uh this
giant uh a problem that was going on in
Ohio and that nobody was talking about
until well after the fact and so I I
commend him photo if it is a photo op
because it sure it shines a light on the
problem let's say it's a photo up Biden
couldn't give a damn to take a picture
yeah Biden couldn't show for 10 minutes
get a picture and leave he could not
even do that you can't speak Ukraine's
very important you know uh how many
people in the United States can point to
Ukraine on a map yeah how many people
United States can tell you can name
three cities in Ukraine or any uh what
do they say oblast is that is that the
territories they use I don't know States
most people don't even know what it is
or where it is and many of these people
are flying the flag but I tell you this
ask somebody where Ohio is to be honest
a lot of people might not wear nowhere
Ohio is but most Americans probably do
and they know it is America and my
question is just Why uh why are my tax
dollars going to Ukraine and not to East
Palestine
this is all good for Trump like there's
no downside to this and everything that
that President Biden is doing right now
is at best only popular with the
Democrats and with his base and so I
just like you can't you can't criticize
Trump for any of the stuff he's doing
it's it's it's it's it's all like you
said 2016 Trump it's all good Trump it's
all all exactly what he needs and the
even the remarks he's making and the the
you know he's being that funny kind of
same dude that people that like Trump
really really like the every man Trump
you know even though he's a billionaire
right that he can connect with people
that aren't billionaires and that's you
know he grew up in New York and and
that's part of that culture and so I
think that's what's been missing from
his campaign and from his Persona since
he's really been cut off from the
American people in in the way that made
him popular in the first place you know
my favorite story was the well done
steak with ketchup and how the corporate
press attacked him for it those that are
long-standing fans of the show have
heard me mention the story probably a
dozen times but Trump was ragged on by
CNN because he ordered a it was like a
38 30-day dry aged steak well done with
ketchup and I'm just like a lot of lower
lower and working-class people who get
steaks from the grocery store that are
not high quality we'll cook it through
and splash ketchup on it because they
can't afford a 30-day dry aged filet
mignon or or you know whatever
Donald Trump was basically signaling to
regular working people he ate the way
they ate and they mocked him for it and
when they went on TV and said Donald
Trump what an idiot for doing this the
people sing at home were cutting into
their well done steak with ketchup going
why you're making fun of me like I'm
literally doing this right now Trump
trump knew how to play them this is what
we need to we need to see more of but I
want to show you this too this one
matters this story right here from WTAE
ABC Giant Eagle pulls Water bottled near
East Palestine from store shelves now
why is that why would a grocery store
remove water bottles from a spring that
was near East Palestine from their store
shelves why would they stop selling
water
that was uh near this toxic waste dump
if the water is safe to drink the water
is fine that's what they said and uh and
the air is fine but this store won't
sell you the water you know I'll tell
you this if the government comes out and
tells you the water's safe and then you
drink it and you get sick why would they
care if you sue them they're giving you
your money back to you it's your tax
dollars oh no we got sued here's your
money back here's the money we took from
you back now if giant eagle gets sued
uh-oh that's their profits that's coming
out of their shareholders pockets so
what I see is when the private sector
says get the water off the shelves
they're seeing something wrong when the
government says everything's fine go
ahead and drink the water they're
probably lying who was it that did the
video where they dragged JD Vance JD
Vance drag a stick across the bottom of
a river and you see all the oils and
chemicals come up to the surface and
these colored rainbow okay that's still
that's still in the muck and what does
this mean when you talk about water
you're talking about food too oh yeah I
mean Farmland chicken is everything
that's out all around there but just the
the food the crops that are going to
grow around this place that would go out
to probably grocery stores all over the
country and definitely in Ohio you know
what does it mean for the food supply
fortunately I don't think it's gonna be
that bad relative to what nuclear
Holocaust or like Chernobyl because what
I'm reading about the uh the chemicals
is that they have a very short half-life
like uh what was the main one vinyl
chloride has like a 2.3 day Half-Life so
after a week you've got about 15 fifteen
percent of the 25 of the chemicals no
after after a week you've got like 12
and a half percent of it left in the air
and then after a few more days you've
got like six percent of it left so we've
already seen 98 of the vinyl chloride
disperse out of the air uh it's really
their concern is the benzenes if there
were a lot of benzenes in the in the
fires they said there were not the
official report is that it was Benzene
residue I don't know if you should
necessarily believe the official report
but when Benzene Burns it creates
dioxins which are persistent and those
can stay in the air and in the soil for
a long time as far as I've read Ryan
Ellis super chatted saying politico's
already attacking them and so Politico
has this semi-round about attack on
trump it says Trump's visit to Ohio
derailment gives Biden's team some
Breathing Room his planned appearance
near the scene of this most toxic
derailment has Democrats pointing to his
past efforts to roll back train and
chemical regulations and there it is the
corporate press will find a way to make
it a negative thing for Trump man I I
think let's get some people some burgers
man and I think it's more indicative of
the fact that we spent a year and a half
calling everything but infrastructure
infrastructure right I mean if there was
a problem with the rail yard and we're
doing this giant infrastructure building
you've got Democrats coming out and
calling you know underwater basket
weaving classes infrastructure right
that you you saw a lot of that so you
had a lot of this this pork that passed
the 1.2 trillion dollars worth of money
going towards things that had nothing to
do with infrastructure and and this is
what comes of that so they're going to
try to spin it back on him but weren't
we supposed to be fixing the railways
weren't we supposed to be doing that do
you think that if Biden or booty judge
showed up they'd boo him out yes like
just yell at them at this point I don't
know it depends on what they should if
they showed up with huge pallets and
pallets of water and food probably not
um you wouldn't see you wouldn't see
Buddha judge or Biden do that why was
Biden not has not gone is it a health
well
District 72 percent of this District
voted for Trump right to point out Ian's
persistent with all due respect naivete
in terms of who these people really are
and you know often on the show you'll
talk about pardoning people or giving
them the benefit of the doubt and it's
like yo man when people tell you who
they are believe them when Joe Biden
sneaks off to Ukraine with 500 million
dollars and ignores This Disaster in its
entirety and then outright his he don't
even address it his people like you're
not coming there Buddha doesn't even
show up he's telling you outright he
does not care about regular
working-class Americans what I wonder is
who who's decide I think I think of
Biden on a leash when I think about
Biden I don't think he's making the
decisions about whether or not he goes
to East Palestine I feel like someone's
like no it's too risky for your
condition Joe you can't breathe that air
in your 80 85. but they're telling us
that they are safe yeah they're bad
people they're evil people I'd like to
know when this trip was planned you know
was it was it just a last minute thing
to for Trump no foreign
you would think that it would be have to
be planned in a while but if it wasn't
that could be an indication that maybe
this was an effort to get eyes away oh
you know what I'm saying I don't know oh
I see yeah I had the feeling that it had
been on track for a while no one knew
about it but they were like just gonna
do it on this day anyway and then the
East Palestine thing was inconvenient to
talk about because it was in the way but
you make a good point maybe they were
just like we need to divert eyes to
something now we need another Chinese
balloon right yeah did he take Hunter
with him
over there I don't think he did but no
oh the more the more distraction he can
he can generate from this exactly I just
I 500 million dollars man that would I
mean the people who live near this train
derailment that train company probably
should compensate them for the fair
market value of their properties before
the damage absolutely and they can keep
the property but ain't nobody buying
those houses now right so what do we get
Donald Trump
he shows up
there's a lot of things he'd be playing
golf right now but this is where I think
he's getting back into the swing of
things and uh I gotta be honest you know
there's a lot of things Trump do that I
chuckle at Raw my eyes at but when I saw
this video of him coming down there I
got a warm fuzzy feeling inside I'm like
at least someone's doing something I
don't care if Trump doesn't care maybe
he's just like here's a great
opportunity to get attention and I'm
like wow he thinks that helping the
American people will make people like
him Joe Biden just left even he didn't
even care that much just like you said
even if it is just a photo op it's he's
still actually like putting food in
people's bellies and giving people water
so but but but right but I'm what I'm
saying as well is Trump if it is a photo
op he's thinking to himself this will
make people like me yeah okay good yeah
he he wants people to like him he has a
concern about whether or not the
American people like him Joe Biden
doesn't no he's just gone thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live my Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time